>> THIS WEEK THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION SAID IT WOULD BE
SUSPENDING THE PROTECTED STATUS
LABEL FOR IMMIGRANTS FROM EL
SALVADOR.
NO JOURNALIST HAD HEARD ABOUT
IT UNTIL THIS WEEK AND ALL OF A
SIGNED NOTHING THIS BAD HAS
EVER HAPPENED.
THE MOVE AFFECTS 200,000 PEOPLE
FROM SALVADOR ALLOWED TO LIVE
AND WORK HERE SINCE 2001 WHEN
AN EARTHQUAKE HIT THE COUNTRY.
TEMPORARY PROTECTED STATUS
ALLUDES TO WHAT ITS PURPOSE WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE.
SUPPOSED TO PROVIDE SHORT-TERM
REFUGE FOR VISITORS FROM OTHER
COUNTRIES IN SHORT TERM
DISORDER.
THAT'S NEVER WHAT HAPPENS.
THEY BECOME AN ILLEGAL
COUNTRIES RATHER THAN PEOPLE OF
A SPECIFIC AGE.
PEOPLE ARE PROTECTED FROM
DEPORTATION AND GIVEN WORK
PERMITS EVEN IF THEY CAME TO
THE U.S. ILLEGALLY.
THE EXCUSE FOR THIS IS NOT
BAD.
AND ANOTHER 57,000 HONDURANS
BECAUSE OF 1998 HURRICANE MITCH
20 YEARS AGO OR THE 51,000
HAITIANS ALLOWED TO STAY HERE
BECAUSE OF THE 2010 EARTHQUAKE
IN THAT COUNTRY.
IT'S HE LAOETS IN WASHINGTON
LETTING HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
ORDINARY IMMIGRATION CHANNELS.
YOU CAN TELL THAT NOBODY EVER
EXPECTED FOR THEM TO RETURN
HOME.
A MASSIVE CRISIS FOR SOME
REASON.
MONDAY "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
COMMENTED ON THE SENSE OF DREAD
GRIPPING EMPLOYERS IN
CALIFORNIA, TEXAS AND VIRGINIA
THOUSANDS OF LOW-WAGE WORKERS
IN THOSE PLACES AND EMPLOYERS
WHO RATHER NOT HAVE TO PAY HIGH
THOUSANDS OF FUTURE STATE VOTES.
THAT'S WHAT IT IS ALL ABOUT.